all right guys
bang bang what's up lunch money time
that's right we got microphones now
we told you we were going to get a
little improvement and we're improving
uh well while she's trying to get rich
for us so let's just try to get our
lunch money right i'm here with the
beautiful
intelligent pelina pompliano she's got
her guns out
sun's out guns out what's up or should
we go sun's out thighs out
also i'm wearing a crop top and he goes
is that a real shirt
[Laughter]
i don't know i didn't guys don't wear
crop tops so
unless you're uh i guess drinking some
bud lights with the mullet hanging out
in the back of a jeep that you turned
into a pool
but uh no problem who's sponsoring this
podcast anthony
block fi they got three products you can
buy and sell crypto
you can deposit crypto and get a us
dollar loan
against your collateral or you can
deposit crypto and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account
block fi get money get paid and
basically now we got microphones i feel
like a radio
uh talk show host would you like to uh
you do have a nice voice i will say that
i have a soothing voice and a face for
radios perfectly made for this moment
all right what's up with the first topic
go to blockfy.com
lunch money and go get your lunch money
at block five all right the s
p 500 rose on tuesday putting it on the
cusp of a fresh all-time
high amid a rotation out of technology
shares and into stocks
that would benefit from a reopening of
the economy and a vaccine
such as cruise lines and airlines just
wait till we get to the vaccine topic
but
first of all like what do you think how
is it possible that in the midst of a
global pandemic
we're almost at an all-time high i mean
look we're pretty close
uh to where we're basically flat really
to the beginning of the year
um and so if you would have told people
hey there's gonna be a global pandemic
there's gonna be a recession and yet
stocks are still gonna be
uh flat to the beginning of the year
which is almost an all-time high
i think they would have told you that
you're absolutely crazy but
remember that's because the government
stepped in they pumped trillions of
dollars into the economy
uh into the stock market and so
uh this is what happens the rich get
rich to the poor get poorer we're
literally watching
the billionaires in america jeff bezos
has added 40 billion dollars to his net
worth
since the start of this i have not added
that much
most most americans have actually lost
their jobs right not most but
uh 50 plus million americans have lost
their jobs but
billionaires have added over uh half a
trillion dollars to
their net worth so what ends up
happening is the rich get richer the
poor get poor and it's all due to
government intervention they're printing
all this money
and i don't think they're done yet
they're still obviously trying to figure
out uh what the next stimulus package is
gonna be
but this is what happens so get yourself
protected after you get yourself
educated what's up next
get yourself educated sorry
she gets a microphone and now all of a
sudden thinks that she's madonna
facebook facebook unveiled the new group
to pursue payments and commerce
opportunities and put
david marcus co-creator of facebook's
libra cryptocurrency project
in charge of the initiative called f2
internally short for facebook financial
they love a good like what is the other
one f8 it's like why don't you just
pronounce it
fate it's so dumb why fa it's fate
okay sure the team will run all
payments projects including facebook pay
the company's universal payments feature
that it plans to build inside of all of
its app
so what's going to happen to libra well
libra's probably part of it
oh right uh you need to move closer to
the microphone this is
you're not an expert do i have to like
touch it like no like just like let's go
like this like right here okay oh oh
go ahead there you go all right you
ready yeah did you hear what i said
i did do you know what apple pay is yes
this is basically like facebook pay
it sounds like what they're trying to
build people gonna see me smile like
this
well you just dart your head out smile
and then there you go
um no so i think basically when it's
going to end up happening here
is um facebook oh yeah it is called
facebook page oh shocking it's like i
read the internet or something or i just
would understand what they're doing um
yeah i wasn't listening
uh but just like apple pay is uh a
universal payment feature
facebook pay is the same thing but
what's really interesting is they're
gonna build inside
all of its apps so so instagram even
instagram
whatsapp uh facebook right all these
different applications if they add this
uh it makes a lot of sense and part of
what is going to be interesting to see
is this
microphone smells bad
sorry go on now you know what it's like
to live with you uh
[Laughter]
um and so what'll be interesting is
what's the underlying technology do they
use digital currency only do they use
more traditional payments
my guess is that they go with a uh a
multi
uh prong strategy are they gonna use the
crypto thing in here
that's what i'm saying is they they're
probably gonna use traditional payment
methods and also incorporate the digital
currency as well
right kind of be able to do both yeah
inside of facebook but libra didn't
really pan
out for facebook the way it thought it
would right why not
what has libra been used for yeah but
they said that they weren't going to
launch it until next year oh i didn't
hear that
yeah well it's all right you don't read
the internet
what's up with mcdonald's drama in
mcdonald's land
uh so mcdonald's last year uh fired its
ceo
stephen easterbrook for having what he
and the company described as a
consensual relationship with an employee
so he left with a compensation package
reportedly worth more than
40 million eight months later mcdonald's
is suing
its former ceo to recoup the money
claiming he had sexual relationships
with multiple employees
and try to cover them up and here's the
kicker he even
gave he hold on one second the the suit
further alleges that easter brook
approved an extraordinary stock
grant worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars for one of the workers he was
having a relationship with
well yeah before i say some crazy stuff
all i'm gonna say is uh in this case
it sounds like for this one worker
sleeping with the boss paid off
but now they're caught uh
hold on that is all everything i just
said based on the allegations is the
worker
slept with the boss and then got
multiple people by the way
the company's case against easter brook
includes dozens of naked or explicit
photographs and videos of different
women
including some mcdonald's employees that
easter brook allegedly
sent his attachments to his personal
email account from his work account
in late who is this idiot dude you're
the ceo of mcdonald's just get the
mcgriddles popping
get the mcchickens going make sure that
the mcflurry machine works at every
mcdonald's and you're just chilling
like you're gonna get mad at me for
saying this but like
there's plenty of people in the world if
you wanna have sexual relations with
people
go find somebody who just doesn't work
at mcdonald's like there's more people
in the world that don't work at
mcdonald's than do
that's all i'm just saying mcdonald's is
still the best restaurant in america
this guy left uh it'll be very
interesting to see as they say
uh possession is nine tenths of the law
and so it sounds like he's got the 40
million dollars and they're trying to
get it back
uh it would be much different obviously
if mcdonald's had the 40 million dollars
and he was suing them to get the money
so it it usually is uh whoever has it
has an advantage which sounds like he's
got the money and they want it so we'll
see how that plays out by the way do you
do other people get in trouble in these
situations you're so dumb
why yes they do no no i'm saying like
the
uh the workers or do they just go after
the boss
i don't know just ask him all right
what's up with softbank softbank swings
to profit after record loss is vision
fund
recovers what what did they do the
softbank vision fund
reported an 18 billion dollar loss last
year and recorded an investment gain of
2.8 billion for this quarter
i guess its stock is up but where did
the
quarterly a 12 billion dollar quarterly
profit where did that come from
so it lost 13 billion last year and then
it just made 12 billion in the quarterly
profit
it's been bolstered by new stock market
listings and the u.s home insurance
startup
lemonade which softbank backed for 300
million and it is now valued at over 1
billion
yeah that's weird though because i guess
uh
if they made 12 billion in quarterly
profit why
is lemonade that's only 1 billion of the
12 billion
uh and their share price increase with a
share buyback plan
shocking and plans to sell
41 billion worth of assets to buy back
shares in the company and reduce
debt so it looks like they're doing a
bunch of financial engineering uh and
then on top of that they
also are uh reaping the rewards of some
of their investments
they've not now gone public as well
right yeah there's this also there's
this chip designer company arm
and there's been talk that it's topics
considering selling it
or listing it to take it public yeah but
basically
they needed cash they burnt through you
know literally billions of dollars last
year
and so in order to get cash uh they were
willing to sell assets and do whatever
they need to sounds like that actually
is
paying off what i will say for those
that don't know is
uh was it my myashi son masayoshi
masayoshi
masa a lot of people don't know this but
he's been the richest man in the world
twice
so he made a fortune was the richest man
in the world in the 1999
uh 2000 internet bubble lost it almost
went broke
then gained it all back now is kind of
making a big bet puttering along uh
somewhere in between
so pretty uh pretty interesting well she
knew that softbank was either gonna be
really big or a complete disaster
softbank or softbank vision function
softbank vision function oh the vision
fund for sure i mean anytime you raise
100 billion dollars
and you uh go deploy really fast like
we'll see what happens okay so you know
how we
that's my alarm it means i got things to
do in 30 minutes
so you know how you're talking about the
vaccine yes
okay well apparently russia
is claiming that they are has they have
registered the world's
first coronavirus vaccine and putin says
that uh his daughter has already taken
it
vaccine against covet wait wait what
wait what the rest of the world is like
hold on a second you mean to tell us
that
you developed this so fast you rushed it
through it's already in like phase three
or phase four
yeah all right so supposedly
putin said as far as i know a vaccine
against a new coronavirus infection has
been registered this morning for the
first time in the world
although i know that it works quite
effectively it forms a stable immunity
and i repeat has passed all the
necessary checks i repeat
no data has yet been published by the
researchers
so this is a complete uh vladimir putin
yeah i'm sorry but i wouldn't take a
vaccine from russia i don't think
and he also said that one of his
daughters has been vaccinated against
the coronavirus commenting that quote in
this sense she took part
in the experiment end quote i don't know
if it counts yeah i don't know if it
counts as having a
vaccine if you're still calling it an
experiment
well no i mean there's supposedly
at the end of july there's 26 candidate
vaccines in the clinical evaluation
stage
including the one registered in russia
that was developed by
this group but russia has denied that it
is part of an
arms race to develop a vaccine saying it
wants to cooperate with other nations
there has been international skepticism
that russia has developed an effective
and safe vaccine
anthony fauci for instance has cast
doubt on the approaches to testing in
russia and china okay so my question is
if the us develops a vaccine and like
russia doesn't like the us or
they are the russians gonna take it
probably not
one probably not two i don't know if dr
fauci
uh his uh track record is suspect why
uh do you remember when he was telling
us all masks don't work don't buy don't
buy masks i don't conflate people i
don't think
i'm pretty sure it was him okay i'm
almost positive it was him
and it came out later on that uh
he knew that masks worked if it was him
uh i'm pretty sure it was that he knew
mass worked he didn't want
there to be like global fomo for all the
ppe and therefore that's why they were
telling people
somebody fact check us all right what's
up with uh mr kane brown
so kane brown this is a great story
kane brown moved into a new house
recently
he owns 30 acres of 3000 around him
and he told his wife he's gonna go check
out the property be back in 30 minutes
he ventured out only in shorts and a
t-shirt along with his friend
and friend's girlfriend 30 minutes
turned into three hours
and then it got dark it dropped to 40
degrees and he got lost on his own
property and police had to come get him
so he got lost on his own property
and they had to use gps to get back but
it kept taking us to all these different
cliffs that you can't drive a
four-wheeler down and i wasn't about to
leave them
so i called my last resort a guy a
fellow musician ryan upchurch who lives
in the area
and up church and one of his friends
found the group but now three turned
into five of us lost brown said
he's got four other friends riding
around in an atv
and they start getting shot at what my
buddy's girl who has
asthma started then freaking out we had
to get her out
so so we call the cops the cops arrive
and hear the gunshots and think we are
shooting at them
we yell at them and tell them we are not
armed and made it out this sounds like
the most ridiculous story ever
but the best part is i can guarantee
he's gonna make a song out of it wait
who is shooting at them
i'm so lonely that i got lost on my own
property
you can just see the sign writes itself
it's like every country song they have
three things they drink beer they have
their pickup truck and their dog
i love that ryan up church his buddy
started defending him being like
okay look i see all the memes and stuff
about cain brown
yeah they're kind of funny but here's
the fact of the matter man you weren't
there
i was there yeah your ass was lost in
the woods too no i think up church was
the one who came and
tried to save them tried but then he got
lost that's the whole thing is he said
he turned in from three people lost to
now we have five people lost
oh no i mean it's pretty funny by the
way
if you've ever been in the woods and got
lost it ain't nothing to 40 degrees and
you were getting
shot at why were they getting shot at
this this article did not answer my
question plane is on bestlifeonline.com
looking at jokes right now
all right what's your joke hold on hold
on don't look though i'm not looking
all right okay
okay hold on okay
uh okay what do you call a clown who's
in jail
a clown that's in jail yeah a criminal
no
what a silicon silicon
silly con oh
[Music]
that one wasn't that good i'll find do
you want to try another one
okay what do you call a computer that
sings i don't know
a dell oh adele
not i know
i know what do you call cheese that
doesn't belong to you
nacho cheese see i got the funny jokes
i'm the guy with the jokes you ain't got
no jokes i got real jokes
one all right guys that's it for lunch
money today hopefully the sound is
getting better
we got to get some decorations for the
back back there get a little studio
action maybe get a little big ass
lunch box to put pulling his head in but
that's it for lunch monday today we will
talk to you guys
tomorrow bye bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends